Besides coffee enemas, what's the best non-invasive way to detoxify the liver?
Well, you could go back to the 7 phases of detox course that you all have access to if
you really want to understand this because you're supported detoxification of the liver
with different herbs, different supplements that I have you on.
And again, it's not just detoxification of the liver, it's everything downstream from the liver.
Are you helping decrease the viscosity of bile to help bile flow so it doesn't get clogged
up in your gallbladder?
Are you helping with your bowel movements so that you're able to make sure that you're
not holding your feces too low, that a reabsorbied stop?
Are you using binders so that you don't reabsorb stuff and put things right back into the
bloodstream and put more stress on your liver?
So the other things that you could do are things that we've talked about before using
castorol packs over your liver, putting hot packs over your liver, those are kinds of things
that could be very beneficial for helping support your liver pathways besides different
herbs and nutrients that are supporting phase 1, phase 2, phase 3.